some exciting news disneyland is finally  reopening to the public on friday and  they did have a bit of a test run last  night look at this  sleeping beauty's castle was lit up once  again and ready to welcome back visitors  isn't that a pretty sight to see  so disneyland will be at 25 to 35  capacity  the park as you know has been closed for  a year and today is a soft opening for  cast members families  being back here being part of it seeing  everything feeling it smelling popcorn  i'm going to go inside and kiss the  ground he's really excited  during the closure disneyland reimagined  snow white's enchanted wish  ride and the splash mountain ride as  well disney california adventure  is set to open on friday of this week  and again  for now it's only for california  residents so we will have to wait a bit  longer